on November 7 2022 Sam bankman freed
woke up with 16 billion on November 8
his net worth plummeted to less than 1
billion according to the Bloomberg
billionaires index
it's one of the greatest single day
financial losses ever
man freed was the co-founder and CEO of
the cryptocurrency exchange FTX like
what's the extra factor x of Sam bankman
freed there quantum mechanics how so
um uh no and it's an interesting
question and I think the the most
interesting thing about it is that there
isn't an obvious answer those words ring
true now more than ever FTX used to be
worth 32 billion but has now filed for
bankruptcy on November 11 he summed up
the mess in a series of tweets including
this I'm sorry I effed up and should
have done better
ironically he recently criticized Mark
Zuckerberg for bleeding money on the
metaverse leading to mass layoffs at
meta which I did a video on
his fortunes have now taken a similar
turn or perhaps his misfortunes are more
like the fictional Russ hanneman from
HBO's TV show Silicon Valley
986 million
I'm not a billionaire anymore Richard
I'm a 986 yaner which isn't even a
[ __ ] thing
I'm out of the three comma Club the
sudden fall of FTX came as a shock and
we'll have repercussions for anyone
interested in investing in crypto
yet upon closer inspection it's no
surprise FTX failed this video will
uncover why
bankman freed grew up on the campus of
Stanford University where both his
parents taught law he worked as a Wall
Street Trader before co-founding FDX in
2019 alongside former Google employee
Gary Wang FTX was backed by high-profile
Venture Capital firms and became one of
the world's largest digital currency
exchanges her customers buy sell and
store various cryptocurrencies very
excited to talk to Sam bankman free the
CEO of FTX and now you are one of if not
the leader of this industry the 30 year
old was hailed as the next Warren
Buffett and attracted the rich and
famous with FTX I have everything I need
to buy sell and trade crypto safely NBA
star Stephen Curry became an ambassador
I'm getting into crypto with FTX so do
the NFL's Tom Brady who personally
invested in FTX the FTX brand was
everywhere on the arena where the Miami
Heat play though it will now be named on
Mercedes Formula One race cars though
those stickers will now be removed
Sam bakeman freed or SBF as he's called
became one of the richest people in the
world his net worth reached a high of 26
billion you couldn't tell by looking at
him he slept on a bean bag at the office
and drove a Toyota Corolla he did
Splurge a bit though he lives in a
luxury Penthouse in the Bahamas with a
golden doodle named gopher and 10
roommates
apparently his roommates all dated each
other at some point a person familiar
with the matter told the crypto news
site coindesk the whole operation was
run by a gang of kids in the Bahamas
some were former co-workers some he met
at his alma mater MIT and one he dated
Caroline Ellison the CEO of Alameda
research Alameda research was a trading
firm founded by bankman freed although
Alameda and FTX were meant to be
separate businesses their ties were
unusually close coindesk reviewed a
leaked document that appeared to show
that Alameda held an alarmingly large
amount of the cryptocurrency created by
FTX called ftt the document revealed 40
of alameda's assets were an ftt
technically that's not illegal but it
did prove that Alameda was heavily
dependent on its sister company rather
than relying on an independent asset
like other cryptocurrencies or fiat
currency which would have been less
risky because their Financial Health was
tied together the failure of one company
would risk destroying the other and
that's what happened
so how did the mess begin
when the crypto Market crashed in the
spring bankman freed wanted to save
struggling crypto companies by relying
on risky bets from Alameda Alameda
committed half a billion dollars to
finance crypto lender Voyager digital he
said he felt a responsibility to act
first of all she's backstopping
customers and making sure they're
protected but second of all stopping
contagion from spreading through the
ecosystem he was seen as a savior and
that matched the image he wanted to
portray to the world he promised to give
away most of his wealth but his desire
to save other crypto companies ended up
hurting his own companies
when Voyager digital filed for
bankruptcy protection a month later
Alameda lost 500 million dollars
Alameda was in trouble
in order to save it from imploding
bankman freed then propped up Alameda by
secretly transferring 10 billion of
customer funds from FDX to Alameda
according to Reuters
he reportedly built a back door in fdx's
accounting software that let him move
billions of dollars without flagging the
transactions to anyone including
external auditors
but bankman freed says it's not how it
looks in text messages to Reuters he
wrote we didn't secretly transfer
we had confusing internal labeling and
misread it without elaborating further
the story gets crazier a large portion
of customer funds is now missing at
least a billion dollars worth of
customer funds have mysteriously
vanished reports Reuters and the story
gets even crazier someone also stole
hundreds of millions of remaining funds
at FTX the new CEO of FTX confirmed that
there was a hack and the company is
cooperating with law enforcement it
could lead to criminal charges
when the financial ties between FTX and
Alameda first surfaced in that article
by coindesk it worried binance the
world's largest cryptocurrency exchange
binance was an early investor in FTX it
decided to offload 580 million of fdx's
native token ftt Finance co-founder and
CEO Chiang Pang Xiao confirmed his
company's Mass selling was due to recent
Revelations alluding to the Cozy ties
between bankman Freed's two companies
finance's Mass selling caused the price
of the token to plummet then other
customers also pulled out fearing this
was yet another failing crypto company
they rushed to withdraw 6 billion in
just three days and FDX couldn't meet
demand as FTX looked doomed to die
binance offered it a Lifeline by
agreeing to acquire the company
Zao or sisi as he's commonly known
planned to bail out his arch rival
but then the bailout didn't happen
Finance backed out as a result of
corporate due diligence and also
mentioned the reports of mishandled
customer funds an alleged U.S agency
investigations
U.S Regulators are reportedly
investigating whether FDX illegally used
customer funds to prop up Alameda fdx's
sudden Fall From Grace has further
tarnished an industry that's still
recovering from the collapse of crypto
prices in May amid Rising interest rates
the spectacular fall of FDX could bring
more regulation to the crypto industry
the U.S bans a risky type of crypto
trading in which investors borrow money
to make huge bets on the future price of
crypto ftx's American arm is for basic
trading to comply with U.S regulations
bankman freed had lobbied lawmakers for
more friendly regulations and donated
Millions to the Democrats including 5
million to Joe Biden's 2020 presidential
campaign and groups supporting him
The Fallout from FTX will take months if
not years to resolve lawyers have to
decide whether the exchange can operate
and then there's the issue of all the
customers who just want their money back
FTX halted withdrawals until further
notice the question for consumers and
companies is how much they'll be able to
recover through the bankruptcy process
the new CEO of FTX is veteran Wall
Street bankruptcy lawyer John Ray who
handled the cleanup of Enron which was
the largest bankruptcy in U.S history at
the time Enron had liabilities of 23
billion fdx's liabilities may be double
that amount as much as 50 billion
according to Illegal filing in U.S
bankruptcy court in Delaware
when bankman freed resigned as CEO he
said I'm really sorry again that we
ended up here hopefully this can bring
some amount of transparency trust and
governance
for customers those are just empty words
crypto is still a new and relatively
untested Market despite the pains right
now many believe it is the future of
Finance if you'd like to learn more
about how crypto works you can learn
about the math and technology behind
cryptocurrencies through Hands-On
puzzles on brilliant's website and app
you can learn the mechanics of
maintaining and securing a
cryptocurrency and then you can decide
for yourself if crypto is a fad or the
next big thing my viewers also love
Brilliance computer science fundamentals
course where you can learn the
fundamentals of computer science and no
coding is required it's great if you're
in school or if you're already in the
workforce and want to brush up on core
computer science Concepts brilliant is
great for anyone who wants to improve
their stem skills you can start your
math journey by looking at fractions
percents and ratios in everyday context
I personally love going through their
logic courses and they've helped improve
my critical thinking skills brilliant is
free to try out if you head to the
custom link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who use my custom link will
get 20 off Brilliance annual premium
subscription which gives you access to
all of their course offerings thanks for
watching for a news think I'm Cindy Palm